YEAR.
MET EIGHT TIMES.
THE RED WINGS WERERE
ANOTHER ROOKIE.
SAVE MADE THE OPENING MINUTE.
NOW TANNER JEANNOT HAS RED WING
PUT RIGHT INTWO-
YEAR CONTRACTCTTHE ICE.
YOU ARE RIGHT INTOTOORS.
>> Willy: A SCORELESS FIRST,
>> JUUSE
WOW.
>> Willy: EKHOLM AND SORROWS
HAD PASSED EACH OTHER AS IF TO
>> Chris: THAT'S A MENTALITY.
THERE GETTING THE PUCK INDEED.
THERE GOING TO THAT DETROIT
RED WINGS DEFEND.
THE PREDATORS , JUST AS AND --
EKHOLM, TWO DEFENSEMEN ON THE
BENCH?
>> Chris: THEY GET A COUPLE
OFF, BUT THIS IS THE BREAD-AND-
BUTTERPERFECT PASS BY PHILIP
FORSBERG, RIGHT TO TAKES OVER.I
>> Chris: THAT WAS A TOUGH OF T
TEAMS.
YOUNG PLAYERS AND THREE KI.
LOOKING FOR
AND THE WORK OF THIS UNIT,
MIKAEL GRANLUND, THSOLUTELY.
>> Willy: A TRUE TOP LINE.
JOHANSSON NOW SOLIDIDI
KAISER,
SAVE FOR IT GOES.
NESTE CAVA CROSS.
PICK UP IN
>> Willy: 20 GOALS FOR
FORSBERG.
20 GOALS FOR DUCHENE.
AND THIS